bonjour et bienvenue sur des modèles tv
pour ces tie-break tie-break des demi
finales du championnat du monde de 2015
championnat du monde féminin donc avec
deux tie breaks
les femmes n'ont pas réussi à se
départager lors des parties longues donc
on a va avoir droit à des parties
rapides de départage deux parties
rapides et puissants aussi égalité
encore doha deux rapides qui suivait
puis enfin on finit par des blitz de
départage si besoin donc nathalie à pogo
nina face à pierre cramier puis dans
l'autre demi finale maria amouzou kfa
s'adonneront navali arica donc on va
tout de suite voir la deuxième partie la
deuxième partie du match entre pogo nina
et crame ling deuxième partie après que
la première partie des partages êtes
nuls donc ici et bien une victoire d'un
côté ou de l'autre et c'est la
qualification pour la grande finale de
ce championnat du monde féminin 2015
alors c'est parti pour les blancs avec
donc natalia pogo ni'lin qui est bien
dans ces demi finales c'est encore une
fois pour la troisième fois consécutive
et bien permis de remonter au score et
donc d'atteindre les tie-breaks fait
trois fois de suite
8e de finale quart de finale
demi-finales où elle revient dans le
match à chaque fois donc ici est là les
blancs et elle n'a pas perdu la première
donc on va voir ce que ça donne c'est
parti avec eux quatre ces cinq donc
sicilienne kalyev 3 et la cavale et c6
rappelez vous on avait eu droit à la
fois aussi avec à 6 la très tôt une
autre type de variantes
la sicilienne recèle plein de subtilités
qui on prend cavale et prend aussi ce
qu'avait laissé trois dames ses sept
fous deux cavaliers f6 foule 3 à 6 ha
c'est un peu la même structure à 6 et 2
6 et lennar regardent et attendent au
maximum avant de sortir ce foulard
ils attendent de voir ce que font les
blancs petit rock époux becker encore
relatera ming répète cette histoire de
fou b4
on veut faire pression sur ce fou sur ce
cavalier pardon qui protège le pion aux
cas donc le pian 4 étant prises et c'est
pas facile de savoir quoi faire un an ce
type de position
est ce qu'il faut éviter de se faire
doubler les pions ici ou est-ce qu' il
vaut mieux protéger le pion aux 4 mais
comment est bien cavaliers à quatre ça
c'est ça c'est un coup extrêmement
surprenant dans cette ouverture
parce qu'il se heurte à plein réponses
possibles on va pas tout les voir mais
simplement on est obligé de citer quand
même les deux principales ici
si les noirs font cavalier prend 2,4 ce
qui semble tout à fait possible
eh bien regardez les blancs une petite
manoeuvre sur laquelle il faut quand
même avoir du calcul
simplement on fait car il prend ses 6es
ici soit en prendre la dame soit du pion
et l'idée c'est qu'avec le cavaly si on
va attaquer la tour avec le fou alors
imaginons que les noirs face le plus
naturel
b process is puisque ça ramène un pur
vers le centre d'accord d'un procès si
c'est peut-être un peu meilleur que
s'attaque le cavalier regardez ici
simplement on joue dam des 4 et hop de
pièces son emprise ce qui est quand même
embêtant et donc sur l'entreprise
simplement donc je reviens sur dame 3 c6
regarder la manoeuvre est simplement je
joue d'abord les v6 la tour est attaqué
donc il faut la bouger par exemple ont
des 8 est maintenant de nouveaux dam des
cats cette fois le fou est attaqué et
regardez on tape aussi sur le pion g7
donc c'est pas évident si je viens en
fuite je vais me prendre fief 3
lecavalier cloud et voilà alors j'ai pas
sorti le fou j'ai le fou s'il vient au
four viens et suis tue pas prêt de rock
et je vais en retard de développement
pour juste avoir gagné le pion aux 4 qui
risque d'être extrêmement pénible à
gérer
imaginons un juste fou et suite ici par
exemple et bien les blancs suivre et la
voilà probablement par france 3 clous
lecavalier alors on peut le protéger par
f5 voir des cinq disons admettons des
cinq ça semble plus logique puisqu'on
joue vers le centre et puis là
simplement regarder les blancs une
rupture centrale très forte ces quatre
voilà c'est fini le cavalier protège ces
cas donc ça va exploser le centre les
tours vont arriver en jeu tout ça n'est
pas y'a pas de rock le roi est quand
même très mal et donc on va avoir une
attaque contre roy au centre pour un
pion ça va être terrible terrible
terrible donc sur cavalia quatre
voiliers la première solution consiste à
prendre 4 n'est pas bonne à cause de ce
calibre ans et si calais b 6 d'amd 4 et
voilà c'est ce qu'on vient de voir et
l'autre solution
ici c'est non non il n'a pas d'autre
voie là tu sais très bien qu elle prend
1,4 ha oui ici s'il faut quand même
regarder b5
voilà l'autre solution c'est de jouer b5
voilà attaque le cavalier est ici on
peut jouer soit cavale et b6 soit cabaye
prend ses six d'abord calé processus qui
attaquent le fou donc la leyre galère
plus logique sinon de db6 aussi je sais
pas ce que ça donne essayons de voir
caler v6 hop voilà alors ces attaques la
tour et le fou mais regardez alors le
car il est si cette emprise vous dites
oui oui bien sûr mais des raisons de le
dire puisque le fou ici ne contrôle pas
b6 à cause du cavalier simplement sur
dame prend voilà on fait ici au choix
donc pas où on va faire cavalier prendre
6 direct voilà quand il prend ainsi qu'à
y prend 1,6 le fou attaque la dame où va
la dame problème c'est qu'il ya pas
beaucoup de casse pour la dame ici c'est
pris ici ces prix là elle est pas
terrible terrible par exemple je
pourrais jouer à trois ou même ses trois
menaçant b4 et ou à troyes b 4 peu
importe
et la dame serait de venir à quatre
roues sera très faible et puis ici on va
se prendre aussi sans doute un calibrant
g7 par exemple si d'am dam
les bessette mettons par exemple analysé
toutes les variantes c'est pas possible
mais cave à l'étranger cet échec roi est
fluide probablement et simplement on
joue cavalier f5 ou fois ci cela leur
très bon si voix la fois aux 6 et là on
menace de en sortant deux cavaliers de
faire un échec voilà avec un échec est
la découverte extrêmement dangereux
alors il ya des défenses que je qualifie
8 etc
enfin on voit bien que la pour le
sacrifice les blancs ont quand même une
très très forte attaque avec un roi des
rockets et c'est donc tous analyse en
détail
donc là il ya 4 est un coût extrêmement
dangereux qui veut tenter les noirs à
faire des choses un peu un peu punk chi
donc la petit rock voilà pas de problème
pour kramnik pour chrome ling pour
pierre cram ling pardon est ici ces
quatre voilà maintenant c4 donc déjà il
ya plus de b 5 ans possible et on
commence à avoir l'idée des blancs c'est
qu'avec cette manoeuvre on a commencé à
former un étau de ma roxy alors
maintenant bien sûr sur ces 4 le
problème c'est qu'il faut analyser
toujours cavalier prend 2,4 c'est un peu
la même idée parce que c'est pas tout à
fait pareil mais nancy je vous donne des
cats j'attaquerai pas d'un becquet
j'attends qu'il est pas le le fou le fou
ici voilà alors on peut quand même
prendre ces six où on peut jouer aussi
l'intéressant c5 qui en ferme le fourbe
et 4 sachant que pareils à des calibres
ans et 6 avec le fou qui protège ses 5
voilà il ya tout un tas de manoeuvre
donc c'est très dangereux on va pas les
regarder en détail c'est pas le but de
la manoeuvre ont regardé la demi finale
quand même se dérouler mais voilà une
variante quand même voyez pointures et
beaucoup de points tactiques donc ici
les noirs pour éviter de se prendre ces
cinq qui est aussi une menace ces cinq
ans ferme le fou et après il va se
prendre à troyes b 4 et il est pris
voilà il est il est pris donc faux cette
voie là on évite toutes ses variantes
fouet cette vous voyez finalement le
couffo b4 se retrouve presque réfutée
par cette manoeuvre cavaliers à 4 g de
revenir qu'à laisser trois maintenant le
cavaly revient mais c'est pas c'est pas
la même chose puisque le pion est devant
et on a le fameux étonnement roxy on
appelle ça les taux de maroc si quand
les deux pions eu quatre essais cas dans
la sicilienne sont placés
ça empêche quasiment définitivement le
cou des cinq en tout cas ça le rend
extrêmement difficile à envisager des
six courses et un vis-à-vis force assez
classique on a eu plein de fois dans son
championnat du monde vis-à-vis tour
dames toujours intéressant par exemple
on peut menacer avec les blancs ici qu'à
valider cinq attaques la dame attaque le
fou attaque lecavalier 6 et en cas de
prise du pion du cavalier aider
simplement reprend du pied on sait et on
veut bien qu'il ya ici du fait du cloud
âge et bien il y aura reprise en c6
voilà donc c'est envisageable ça veut
pas dire que c'est bon mais c'est
envisageable donc tour c'est un câble et
prend des quatre mois là en prenant ici
on évite cette manoeuvre dame prend et
maintenant qu'à aller 17 ans très bien
qu'à y décèle bon pourquoi pas ça finit
pas le développement bon ça peut-être
que les noirs veulent jouer fou fou f6
c'est possible bon tour eiffe d1 en faut
et si ces morts puisque médecins surtout
ici simplement je prends des six donc b6
voilà alors c'est l'autre idée de calais
17 je protège b6 donc cette batterie
n'attaque pas le pion et on joue b6 pour
sortir le fou en b cette voie là où il
sera très bien avec une jolie les
gonades voilà une belle diagonale
notamment en visant les quatre centrales
des 5 et 4 b 4 rappelle comme c'est des
parties rapides aussi alors békaa de ses
classiques dans l'étau de maroc si haut
si on allait tôt bon c'est très bien
mais qu'est ce qu'on fait faux créé une
rupture on en donne est donc bécade ont
déjà j'enlève la casse c5 ou cavaliers
mais surtout je protège les cases à cinq
essais 5 je peux envisager des ruptures
surtout en c5 pas tout de suite mais au
bon ton d 8 l'appareil vis-à-vis tour
dames cavia cadres alors la menace
passion sur b 6 il faut faire quelque
chose tombait 8
on protège à 3 à 3 parce que à tout
moment lors pu envisager maintenant
devait faire un sacrifice centrale de
pions pour se venger sur le cube et
quatre peut-être voilà avec un vis-à-vis
tour dames il y avait des
descendu des possibilités tactiques dame
ces six attaques lecavalier à 4 donc on
revient fouler cette ça y est pour l'une
auront fini leur développement
finalement les pièces sont pas si mal
placé c'est passif parce qu'ils sont sur
trois rangées 3 traverse on appelle les
traverses en général quand ces deux
travers justement et donc les blancs eux
sont surveillés quatre bons mais ça
c'est un peu du aussi l avantage de
départ des blancs donc les blancs plus
des spasmes et pour l'instant il n'y a
rien de rien est f3 alors ses classiques
en ôta method man auxi souvent on
n'hésite pas on joue f3 donc du coup
cette phalange de pions bien rang se
fout des cet inoffensif c'est à dire que
là c'est un mur contre lequel ils butent
x 8 ou d'attentes mais aussi coude de
protection de la tourbe et 8 sur la
colonne mais ici on on libère on ouvre
on crée une ouverture de défense sur b6
et aussi pourquoi pas envisager un b5
ultérieurement parce que b 5 6 et 5 ça
marche pas à cause d'eux sans doute puis
on prend et puis un vis-à-vis tour dames
aussi l'un qui peut se réveiller
trois chiens alors coup coup à la fois
prophylactique sans doute et puis
d'attentes aussi que font les noirs bon
rachat du coup on n'a pas peur de mettre
ce maître sur la grande diagonale
puisque c'est trois pions quand même son
bouclier infranchissable et on s'enlève
des possibilités ici pour les noirs à la
fin de certaines variantes de faire un
échec sur ses diagonales
après tout un tas des changes kapsys
fouet f-16 bon c'est des manoeuvres ici
dam des deux cavaliers 17 sa attend d'un
f2 allant général cette variante les
noirs attendant voilà tour d'essai huit
dames g3s ipod nano l'art fait à
l'envers cercle
c'est la même que la dernière fois elle
attaque le roi elle commence à mettre sa
dame en g3 la menace est fou prend 1,6
et déjà gagnant gagnant puisque le roy
et louis simplement droit à une suite il
n'ya plus de menace sauf à donner un fou
contre pas d'attaquants puisque si je
prends il n'y a rien derrière
donc vous des 4 attention là par contre
là une vraie menace d'un projet cet
échec est simplement g6 mais n'auront
pas peur bon j'ai si je sais pas si
c'est le mieux quand même ici parce que
le problème de geci c'est que ça
affaiblit maintenant h6 ce qui est pas
fou 3 on l'a bien joué attac la
faiblesse que font les noirs moi j'ai
c'est très bien damages trois badges ou
menacent toujours
voilà je bouge fort succès de forcer les
noirs à s'affaiblir h5 bon très bien
hcm mais regardez les cases noires à
lacets du coup sont tout de suite un peu
plus faible et on a le fou on a le fou
donc ça peut ça peut être pénible
donc on revient sur case noire après
avoir fini le travail
regardez comme elle se presse pas togo
nina et elle joue soucaze noir h4 deux
cavaliers ou 5 menace de prendre en c4
puisqu'il ya que le fou qui défend même
si à une vis à vis tour dames après
qu'harry français 4 quoique je voulais
blanc peut-être on peut consolider leurs
parts soit à b5 soi même des scènes
pourquoi pas
donc c'est une vraie menace mais h3
quand même le pas peur à toi alors là
qu'est ce qui se passe sur cavaliers
france écartent qu'il fallait calculer
ça alors regardez simplement il se
serait passé très certainement fou prend
d'emprunt est maintenant un coup très
fort car les des 5 voilà la dame est
attaqué où va la dame par exemple n'a
pas trop le choix il faut que là il sans
doute en b5 et simplement appris je
gagne le cavalier de 7 en attaquant la
tour sémite
donc ce pion en fait et indirectement
défendu c'est un pion empoisonné dames 8
voilà c'est pas la même la sa menace qui
avait dépensé 4 puisque en cas de prise
de la tournée ça ne marche pas on prend
c'est un abord et puis c'est pas pareil
d'avoir un vis-à-vis tout retour comme
vis-à-vis tour dames bien entendu cavale
et bien voilà donc on protège ses quatre
par la tour regardez il suffit de
libérer la force de ses pièces cavaliers
tour c6 food et 4 attention
cavaillé cloud et donc menace f4 gagne
le cavalier donc on enlève le roi voilà
du clonage f4 quand même
kelly 17 et forcément oui bien sûr alors
maintenant on voit qu'il ya des percées
fcn possible le roi quand même est un
peu affaibli le fait d'avoir poussé ses
pions
bon voilà l'idée calais d2 on ramène
aussi regarder avant de faire des
ruptures la pièce là elle jouait pas on
la ramène en jeu peut-être l'avenir en
f3 menacé h4 qui est quand même un pion
faible un mine de rien alors c'est sûr
c'est un pion que les noirs ont poussé
pour aussi contenir les blancs et les
affaiblir un peu la casse g3 est faible
et les noirs peuvent pas vraiment en
profiter par contre ça peut s'avérer une
faiblesse e5 est noir réagissent aux
centristes entendent que il faut réagir
fouet 3 puis on prend fou prend voilà
cette manoeuvre enlève la possibilité de
la rupture f5
voilà maintenant y'a plus mais on a
ouvert la colonne f ça c'est un problème
aussi parce que colonne fc souvent motif
d' attaque aussi cavalier ou cinq comme
les f3 va pas bon pour l'instant
cavalier prend on ne peut reprendre du
pillon de la dame les deux sombres ont
elles choisi de prendre de la dame pour
une hymne à tour ses 8
dam des trois
pour les fuites
tôt un vis-à-vis classique encore une
fois vis-à-vis tour dames b5 à rupture
proposé puis on prend tout reprend et
fou prend c'est alors ça c'est très joli
cette manière vous prend et patou
reprend regardez là les noirs faut qu'il
reprenne en bessin maintenant et
maintenant foulée 2 voilà très bien joué
des blancs sur cette manoeuvre de
tentative de libération noirs ici on a
pris sept grandes diagonales ici donc on
peut menacer et le roi noir donc là un
rouage 7 est sûr regardez maintenant il
ya une jolie manoeuvre des blancs 1,5
pour ouvrir les lignes au maximum des 5
est maintenant regarder très joli os 6
waouh
alors il ya un vis-à-vis tour dames et
la tour et pas en est pas en prise enfin
elle est en prise par donc si je prends
f7 par exemple mais je me prends ici
dame prend tour mais je peux me menacer
e 7 e set c'est pas la même parce que je
me reprends f8 est pas ce que fait
cavalier avec échec ou même chez les
dames
g
j'ai quand même j'ai gagné une pièce
mais et surtout prend il ya bien sûr un
clouage avec vous et 6 voilà donc c'est
une manoeuvre dangereuse donc il faut
prendre la reprenne et là regardez c'est
très joli
dale des 4 ça y est regardé la grande
valeur ici donc que tout ça a été fait
pour ouvrir les lignes menace damas
schmitt matt bon et une défense
simplement x 6 x 6 passes comme ça
évidemment je libère la défense de la
dame / h vite le fou contrôle g7
heureusement ouf tout est tenu sinon se
faisait mater mais maintenant d'un
proche 4 alors à noter qu'ici sur toile
6 il y avait peut-être des coûts encore
plus fort ici on pouvait aussi jouer un
très joli probablement d'alger car c'est
encore plus fort que de prendre h
théâtre puisque finalement ce pion h4
bon il sera pris tôt ou tard très
certainement aidé à mach 4 menaces à ba2
de rentrer avec la tour à tour prend 1,6
mais bon d'un proche quatre dames f7
[ __ ] en b 5 tours ces deux on voit que
les blancs quand même on quand une belle
position le roi noir est faiblard bron
ça a l'air encore de tenir plus ou moins
de temps que ses pions centraux empêche
la tour de venir jouer
attention quand même aussi les noirs
pourrait se réveiller puisqu'il y à tour
est fou contre-plongée de on est en
partie rapide bon simplement on sent en
haleine quand même le sentiment que les
blancs sont plus actifs parce que ce fou
et loué il est passif tannique les deux
fous blanc son actif on a aussi deux
pions passé la halle l attention et on
voit mal comment par contre les pions
sans trop noir pourrait bouger puisque
le fougueux et très fort donc ici tour
ces deux sous des quatre voilà on
protège le fou bien entendu eu cinq
attaques le fou des quatre la tour
prends mon très bien échec
fujitsu vient pas terrible puisque je me
cloue le jeu me cloue le fou alors est
ce qu'il y avait d'autres solutions
fouzia j'aurais pu jouer bien sûr une
aussitôt un tour ou un hangar dans mes
deux fous très puissant bien me
positionner ce fou ici regardez il est
rendu inactif parce que des cinq le bloc
donc je peux échanger les tours avec
toujours un avantage parce que les fous
sont beaucoup plus actifs que les foules
noir et en plus j'ai très nettement
d'options de plus voilà donc les
échanges sont sont bons on fout juin
pourquoi pas là mais fuite
il a simplement l'autre intéressé de
jouer là mais suit alors la dame et
schwyz un coût faible
ici il aurait fallu très certainement
ici jouer un coup du type dame f4 plutôt
pour proposer à des charges de dames et
alléger la position mais évidemment la
tension est au maximum entre les
joueuses on est en tie break de deux
demi finales de championnats du monde
on avait les nerfs joue beaucoup là ici
d'entamer fuite c'est un coup je pense
nerveux c'est pas c'est pas un coup très
très jolie ses passifs ça défend le fou
puisqu'il y avait quand même voilà alors
il y avait aussi la menace tour cet
échec 1-1 il y avait ici
ici autour cette cloud la dame c'est ça
la menace c'est pour saddam f4 à la fois
protège le fou et menaces afin propose
un échange de dames
c'était sans doute un peu mieux mesdames
et fuite tour huit attaques la dame où
va la dame voilà maintenant d'un f4 très
bien je pense que tours 8 est une femme
une photo si ici il se tord aux 7 à
l'art de gagner tout simplement ici
imaginons tour cet échec
là par exemple berrois g8
parce que salar de l'autre le mieux
puisque j'enlève le clouage sur le fou
est maintenant le problème c'est que
boone tout de suite de toute façon la
dame sera cloué voilà donc après tout s
est en fait trop cet échec la leur on
est obligé de descendre et adam va être
perdu c'est pour ça que dans les fuites
c'est pas c'est pas terrible donc d'un
méchoui tours 8
d'un f4 permetde avec 4 et là bon mais
quand même dame prend f4 fou prend f4 et
là alors un coût très faible des blancs
g3 alors ça c'est pas bon du tout
c'est clair parce que c'est faiblard et
puis ça ça libère en maintenant des
possibilités d'échec du fou à 8
bon c'est ça fait peur quand même et
puis surtout il ya ici regardez un très
joli coup des noirs foule 3 complètement
inattendu retournement de situation
complet incroyable puisque la tour peut
prendre pour garder mais justement échec
au ca s'était pas vu des blancs alors
les blancs à une position gagnante il ya
trois coups il suffisait de faire tout
recettes et pas tour 8
cet échec on l'a vu ça gagne la dame ne
l'ont pas vu probablement ici on est au
55e coulon faut savoir que les joueuses
donc de dix secondes à la pendule pour
jouer leurs coûts et donc évidemment
c'est du quasi blitz et la regarder la
tour est perdu
voilà ce qui est qu il faut parer les
chèques et même si la tour se met en
opposition s'est perdu donc livrant les
noirs vont en voir une qualité de plus
avec une position probablement en
gagnante
même si ça reste difficile à jouer donc
là les blancs ne craint pas tout reprend
fou voilà heureusement ils s'en sortent
avec tout reprend phu tho reprend julien
échec crois-je deux des quatre voies
alors là c'est quand même pas tout à
fait la même
les peaux cité et deux nuls existe alors
les facteurs 2 nuls alors les blancs
sont mieux toujours ici puisqu'il ya
deux pions de plus il ses deux pions
contre ses deux pions mais là il ya de
plus en plus passé lié
c'est très fort petit facteur possible
de nul c'est qu'on a les fameux fou de
couleurs opposées mais il est fou tu que
le reposer ça peut faire nul
s'il n'y a que les fous et encore on a
vu on a vu une finale ou même avec full
couleurs opposées ça gagne pas c'est pas
toujours fait ça fait pas nul ça fait
pas toujours nul mais en plus il ya les
tours alors celui qui attaque ici c'est
à dire que les blancs ce local avantages
apa intérêts dans ce type de finale à
échanger les tours puisque cela augmente
les chances 2 nuls voilà donc tour des
huit tours b1 empêche les pions blancs
d'avancé puisque sur à 4 le pion b4 est
perdu et 2 et là c'est une grande finale
donc on va enchaîner les coups parce que
là ça devient technique tout reprend b53
quatre fous des trois couples à tour la
tour n'attaque plus les pions fou projet
trois tours prend des quatre change de
pions les blancs n'ont plus qu'un pion
plus on est sur du quasi blitz ne va pas
commenter toutes les erreurs qui peut y
avoir il y en a très certainement plein
tour projet 4 gsm pardon sa vie alors
maintenant de nouveau deux pions de plus
2 h 4 donc la possibilité de guez existe
pour les blancs avec les deux pions
éloignés comme ça à la voyez les noirs
ici proposent les changes de tours ici
ça fait nul parce que ce fou on avait
déjà vu une finale comme ça de foot que
leur opposer si les blancs échange on
prend six b6 simplement parvenir en h2
se fout restera sur cette diagonale
donc quoi que fassent les blancs même
s'il amène le roy on prendra tout
simplement avec le fou et ce roi ici et
de la peut arrêter ce pion puisque la
case à chocs 8 et de la couleur opposée
du fou quand on a un pion à oicha finale
puis même pions
son nom awashish ou six en un pion awash
sur la colonne à ou sur la colonne h
pour faire dan avec un fou uniquement
contre roy il faut que le fou soit de la
couleur de la case si le couleurs
opposées ça marche pas sauf si le roi
est coupée et si le roi peut pas arriver
mais si le roi arrive à contrôler cette
case c'est nul voilà donc là là ça
risque ça risque d'être nulle
donc je suis en train de calculer quand
même ah oui en plus il ya échec surtout
quand il vous prend et cake parce que
sinon il y avait 6 ils auront un air de
par pouvoir revenir mais ça marche en
haletant parce qu'on fait les chèques
ainsi 3g cet essai terminé voilà donc ça
serait nulle si les blancs ils changent
donc s'y trompe pas tout réussi cinq
échecs
voilà moi j'ai sept rois ces cinq ans à
faut voir ça en dix secondes
voilà c'est des grands maîtres on est en
2009 championnats du monde
il le savait on le voit au premier coup
d'oeil un tour c'est un tour des scènes
mais d'où l'importance on le voit ici
encore une fois de connaître les finales
standard les finales de base
ces mêmes final que philidor dès le
xviiie siècle a quasiment toutes déjà
analysé expliqué en détail les finales
de base qui est qu'il convient de savoir
et qu'on peut apprendre par exemple donc
avec la fameuse analyse du jeu d'échecs
de philidor qui pour moi représente sans
doute la bible de
de l'apprentissage du jeu d'échecs 3 6 3
mais 4 tomber un échec
passer trois tours c'est un échec
ap trois fous et quatre tours fc nk
fouet trois faux 2 tourne vers 3
12,5 et donc la finale est très longue
on peut pas tout commenter pour
l'instant ça bouge pas le problème pour
les blancs c'est d'essayer d'avancer
leurs pions
on est en blitz donc ça joue vite faut
pas faire de faute il faut pas donner de
pièces échange de tours on l'a vu ça
sera nul donc il faut éviter des changes
et les tours les blancs doivent tout
faire pour remettre les noirs sous
pression ils ont deux pions donc
possibilité de gain réel
voyez on éviterait change de tours
attention manoeuvre à b6 ça y est ça
avance échec
trois tours b 4 blocs l'opium et b cette
voie là on est protégé par le fou et
attention on n'est plus qu'à une casse
de dames et la voilà assis et n'ont
laissé pousser les blancs alors c'est
pas facile parce que sinon on vient de
pêcher ce pions d'avancé sans doute
celle autre pion corpulence et avec des
échecs on aurait poussé le roi on aurait
joué h 6 échecs et ça serait l'autre
pion qui avance voilà j'ai cette droite
at le fou fou 7,6 hop cube et cinq
coupes
aie aie aie aie on sent que ça sent le
roussi fou g3 juste à temps on attaque
la tour quatre otages cinq échecs
voilà l'autre pions doit avancer aussi
échec aïe aïe aïe tour 17 tours b1
empêche de faire dame la menace
attention ici la menace c'est de jouer
b huit dames fou prend tous riches
cheikhs et ensuite tout reprend et puis
j'ai un pion de plus et j'ai encore les
tours non c'est pas la même que quand
y'a pas les tours bien sûr je peux la
gagner c'est la très certainement déjà
que touré fou contre tours encore une
fois fini d'or nous avait montré qu'il
ya plein positions gagnantes de façon
forcée et même quand c'est pas bien de
façon forcée c'est très difficile à
défendre
ça peut se gagner et or il faut
contretemps
à 8 h 6 fou échec c'est le tour b4 fou
détroit attention attention regardez
petit petit couloir parce que le pion
contrôle g7 le fou contrôle h7
voyez donc le roi et dans un couloir
menace tour des huit matt donc roi g8
forcée voilà et la hache cet échec très
jolie attention le fou contrôle h7 si on
joue ici roi ensuite on va se prendre
échec roigé cet échec en g8
le roi alors on va le faire tiens
imaginons roi suite d'accord regardez
simplement en fait tous rishek roi g7 et
forcé le pion h7 est contrôlé par le fou
et maintenant je peux faire simplement
voilà tout simplement d'un échec terminé
donc donc h cet échec 3 f 8
hélas les blanches ou dan magnifique et
les noirs abandonnent
il aurait suivi ici le coup fort c'est
fou prend et simplement regarder
simplement tout rishek croit par exemple
que cette et je prends pas le fou et non
parce que je me prendrais tout reprendre
et 7 non je fais plus fort ah si ça
marche
on peut prendre de fou quand même
regarder puisque surtout reprendre 17
maintenant simplement tout rishek voilà
et enfin on prend la tour avec un gain
facile voilà donc magnifique magnifique
victoire de pogo nina qui revient de
loin puisque elle revient trois fois de
suite en huitième en quarts andoni elle
revient dans le match après avoir perdu
la première du match et un tie break à
chaque fois elles l'emportent est ici
donc elle élimine pia cramer ling
légende du jeu d'échecs qui est sur la
scène internationale depuis des dizaines
d'années et qui est toujours toujours
présente dans les grands rendez-vous et
bien un pogo nina atteint la finale du
championnat du monde d'échecs 2015 alors
on va voir forcément voir maintenant
comment s'est déroulé l'autre demi
finale
on regardera le tableau aussi entre
musique zouk et arica donc ici nous y
tout allait blanc qui était donc
ukrainienne maria am ozzy toute sa soeur
anna s'est fait éliminé au tour
précédent 1 c'est-à-dire en quart de
finale alors qu'elle est un peu plus
jeune que maria est aussi un meilleur
classement d'ailleurs on en a mais elle
s'est fait éliminer par justement pierre
cramier commune voit hélas ici donc
maria aussi choo qui a fait grosse
impression aux tours précédents
puisqu'elle a éliminé piccone roues et
là se retrouve face à une deuxième
indienne c'est arica donc
dro navali arica l'indienne aussi qui
fait un très très beau tournoi est donc
ici on est donc dans la deuxième phase
des tie break c'est à dire qu'après une
première phase il ya eu 1 partout maria
avait marqué le premier point mais arica
est revenu à égaliser et là on est donc
dans la deuxième du de la deuxième phase
des tie break voilà on dans le tableau
final à la fin donc partie décisive et
c'est parti pour donc mozy choo qui
ouvre le jeu par e 4 e 5 4 3 des 6 alors
ça c'est la fameuse justement défense
fille dont on a décidément on peut pas
échapper a fini dans canton compte chez
les ex impossible défense philidor qu
est aussi on a un français qui est
devenu spécialiste mondial de cette
variante il a écrit un excellent livre
sur le sujet c'est bien entendu le grand
maître international christian bauer
christian bauer qui est d'ailleurs
champion de france deux parties rapides
2015 qui a magnifiquement gagné le
tournoi de nancy organisé par christophe
philippe et qui ont un grand spécialiste
de l'afinitor donc des 6 et là des
quatre voies la classique contre la
fille dehors il ya d'autres coups
possibles mais on peut jouer aussi fous
ces quatre c'est intéressant mais bien
sûr des quatre pions prend cavalli prend
4 6 6 3 fawcett fou et 4,4 contre la
case 5,6 peut-être pour pousser scène
plus tard je ne sais pas petit rock
d'amd 2 et voilà une des idées aussi
hop on sort la dame est peut-être on
veut faire un grand roque après à 6m
grand roque alors davantage de jouer le
grand roque ces cantons de gagner
évidemment ça permet
debout c'est les pions à la table du roi
mais les noirs aussi voilà donc on
accepte une partie tendue pour le gain
donc c'est une joueuse datta khel nous
et tout cas là pas peur donc grand roque
est ici bhl et blanc sans doute peuvent
jouer à base de f3 puis g4 g5 des choses
comme ça pour déstabiliser le cac m6 et
pousser les pions contre le roi noir
mais beisheim et sur les noirs font la
même chose
voilà f3 donc d'où l'intérêt de ce genre
de coups alors très très courant quand
on vous a demandé deux camps ont fait le
grand roque le qf31 faut pas hésiter à
le faire c'est très souvent bon coup un
savant sa prothèse sur potes ça protège
très très bien le 4 en cas de foot 17 ce
genre de choses c'est très très bien
défendu et en même temps ça permet aussi
de jouer g4 en étant protégé donc f3
protège à la fois e card et g4 donc est
à la fois défensif au centre et offensif
sur le côté fou 17 ans pression quand
même au centre ici par le fou donc tard
les noirs peut-être four ont percé
centrale en général si on peut le faire
c'est bien mais ce n'est pas évident à
l'absurde et 5 ont peu joué le 5 et le
cavaly sera attaqué la partie centrale
marche pas mais souvent ceux contre une
attaque sur le côté on réagit au centre
cabaye est un galop le problème de
secours voilà c'est que ça permet de
placer 1 cagliari 5 dont kasparov disait
que ça vaut un pion caspar disais qu'il
estimait que s'il peut mettre un carré
viiip 5 il estime qu'il aime c'est comme
s'il avait besoin de plus alors en tout
cas c'est vrai que c'est m carali
extrêmement forts en attaque ça attaque
7 et ça attaque g7 avait des
possibilités de sacrifice ou de 6 de
contrôle ont peu joué par adam et eve
deux hommes g3 sa menace maths par
exemple on peut aussi mettre une dame
sur la diagonale et si on arrive à
bouger ce cavalier savannah smat
bref c'est un cavalier extrêmement
pénible voilà et c'est permis par le
coup fourré cette cavale et huit
voiliers comme les noirs ont peur donc
il m cavaliers pour protéger g7 et
peut-être pour jouer faux et 6 4 qui
défendra non seulement g7 mais aussi
proposera un fou peut-être en attaque
eux mêmes contre le haut le rock mais
aurélie sarabi tg4010 cette cavale et
prend ça me prend
on élimine le défenseur et cavaliers des
cinq attaques la dame
voilà pourquoi pas d'âme six mois bien
qu'à 800 faut deux tours b 8
alors tour des huit mois je sais pas
trop expliquer sur le coup alors ça mais
la tour sera connu et très bien peu
stressé 5 c 4 b 4 je sais pas c'est
peut-être pour prévoir à terme de jouer
d'ouvrir cette colonne contre le roi
blanc mais ça paraît pas terrible quand
même h4 cavalli c4 alors voilà l'idée
maintenant s'il faut prendre pions prend
les atours et bien placé bon peut-être
les blancs je donne ces trois fonds
prend tout reprend bien entendu puisque
sur pied on prend et bien dans la dame
aurait attaqué le fou donc on n'a pas le
choix on reprendre la tour en 2006 et
l'a simplement échanges car il prend et
ici fou prend alors évidemment sur
cavaliers prend en fou prend on a gagné
deux fous contre une tour ce qui est un
avantage colossal end fou c'est beaucoup
plus fort qu'une tour vous invite à
jouer des finales de fou contre une tour
vous allez voir c'est extrêmement
pénible donc plus on prend ces quatre
voilà et simplement vois la tour b 4
maintenant on joue contre la faiblesse
ici on va y aller petit qu'un doublé la
ébranle vu que les dames sont plus là
les attaques sont pas aussi fortes que
quand les dames sont là donc c'est 3
alors ces trois bons effectivement sa
menace pour prendre b2 mais ce pion est
très faible
voilà alors b3 et bon c'est sûr que là
on voit bien que tour ces quatre menaces
avec prise de ces trois voire même on
amène le tour on l'amène en d3 pour et
puis on va prendre ses trois ce pion à
l'air condamné un tour b 5 voix la
tourbe des 1 tour 8
et voilà tour des 3 on aurait pu mettre
le tour peut-être
et ça marche mais h5 créer ces deux
courts et une contre aux menaces mais
simplement voilà on pousse on attaque le
cavalier et sur câble et 17 simplement
voilà ça y est c'est leur boom
on a gagné un pion net pour ses 5
on avait deux ep six attaques j'ai cinq
tours prend
on va les prendre et maintenant puis on
prend regardez comme c'est précis on
prend d'abord la tour ici on peut pas
prendre du plomb parce qu'ils auraient
tour contre laval y est ça et en bout ça
enlève le cavalier de la défense de m 6
et maintenant on prend voilà ça oblige à
reprendre du pillon et voilà de nouveau
deux pions isolé un deux trois pions
isolé alors que les donc les noirs ont
regardé un deux trois quatre îlots de
pions contre 1,2 simplement 3 donc ça
fait autant de cibles quatre cibles
contre 3 il ya plus de cibles à taper
côté noir que l' inverse donc les blancs
ont l'avantagé non seulement d'un pion
mais aussi de la structure tour des 5 et
tout de suite regardé boom cavaliers 6
fou des deux cas les g7 juste à temps
heureusement mais regarder l'autre côté
tu auras 8 et d4 évidemment la menace
des cinq pas tout de suite parce qu'il y
aurait autour des 8 mai b5 et quand même
dans l'air avec l'idée que sur puis on
prend tout reprend tour donc des singles
risque de gagner le pion à 6 il faut
juste protéger la classe b ste croix et
vii d'abord à quatre mois la c6 c4 à
laon surprotège la case on va menacer
mais cinq cavaliers le 6 essais leur
voix la bcn terminer ici terminé c'est à
dire que là le pion ne peut pas
apprendre b5 et donc le plus raciste et
perdu sur ces prend bien on reprend du
poids ou du pion c'est pas simplement
gagner le pion à 6 voilà cavaliers
assène protège mais simplement bien
entendu le fou maintenant attaque
le défenseur est donc c'est mon échec en
c3 cavaliers 5 ça semble cuit pour les
noirs tour prend assise sera dé
magnifiquement bien jouer tous à tour
ses 8 on garde les tours pour se garder
des chances de nuls échec non pas check
pardon b6 les six menacent eux
probablement de jouer à 5 suivi de
behcet ton retour à tourbes et 6 à 6 ans
fermes à tous et les deux pions l'a tout
simplement c'est très difficile à
arrêter
en plus on a un fou contre un cavalier
enfin les blancs tous là ici maintenant
regarder petit à petit comment les
blancs ont profité des imprécisions noir
tout simplement ces cinq échecs de six
tours aux sept ça y est l'autre piquant
qui tombent tous qui tombe c'est
horrible qu'avait laissé six f4 lattre
attention attention attention noir
pardon si ce cavalier bouge f5 échec roi
ou 5 imagine-t-il et regardons un coup
comme cavalier des quatre ici regardez
on jouerait f5 échec la tour empêche le
roi de bouger le roi doit venir en 5 ou
alors on donne le cavalier bon ok sinon
regardez maintenant échec et le roi
regarder ne peut plus bouger
tout est pris par le pion aux quatre ici
la tour contrôle et la sepri par le fou
est ici c'est pris par le roi donc on
est obligé de jouer cavalier six tours
prend maths on est mat en fait on se
fait maths et en plaçant de l'échiquier
ça peut arriver donc attention f4 c'est
la menace fcn toros est donc ça
immobilise ce cavalier en fait tomber 8
et regarder assène donc on peut pas
prendre à cause de la menace qu'on vient
de dire si je prends f5 échec recèle
tour sept matches
ah oui piège y compris enfin finale f 5
échecs repousse le roi regarder quand on
a deux pions comme ça qui contrôle très
bien tout est contrôlé un échec et le
roi est obligé d'être de ceux repoussé
d'aller sur la septième rangée
voilà et là regardez on a tous en prise
ici c'est dire que le pion des six est
visible sur par la tournée sens c'est
pas grave il est protégé mais le
cavalier derrière il pas à protéger
en fait ici avait un coup très fort
c'est simplement fou prend ses 5 et
regarder aussi le psy pions prend tout
reprend et c'est fini on regarde il ya
trop trop davantage blanche
donc bon les blancs choisis sur notre
cookies bon aussi bien sur re5 on prend
pas avec le fou mais on joue aux cinq
ans prenant ici on prenait un peu un
pion au passage là c'est la même menace
est sûre tu en prends tout reprend
cavaliers donc les noirs prennent le
pion à 5 et l'a simplement puis on prend
un échec
trois des sept fous prend et on ramasse
les pions calais 17 attaques le fou fou
des quatre tours 8
ces 5 il va se prendre un échec en h7 il
va être obligé de partir en cavalier des
huit voilà échec
rocé 6 forcé est quasiment échec lors on
est obligé d'aller en b5 et maintenant
bessette
mais cette menace v8 tom câble et c6
juste à temps cavalier protège tour
protège mais simplement regarder le
fameux tour c'est 8
la tour est attaqué évidemment tout
autre entourent pions prendre dames et
en même temps on protège la case but de
promotion donc les blancs sont gagnants
tories tchèques mois des deux tours h3
et simplement tout reprend encore plus
fort que de faire dame bien entendu on
prend le défenseur et maintenant ce roi
prend il y aura dames et on les noirs
peuvent pas empêcher la dame superbe
victoire de
maria amouzou car dans ce tie break 1
suite à une première salve de parties
rapides et bien elle gagne la seconde
salve la seconde manche des tie break
et donc elle élimine l'indienne arica
donc on va voir le tableau final de ces
championnats du monde de ces
demi-finales regardez ici ce qui s'est
passé donc là c'était game un game 2 si
ça c'était les parties longues donc
entre musi tchouk et arica deux parties
nulles donc on n'a pas commenté et puis
ensuite en tie break 1 001 donc égalité
égalisation de arica et dans la deuxième
série de parties rapides avant limites
eh bien regardez donc simplement partie
nulle à la première et enfin donc cette
victoire que l'on vient de voir
finalement assez facile arica et c'est
quand même n'a pas réussi à trouver des
bons coups est simplement elle a joué
des coups faibles et les blancs en ont
profité de façon très précise et donc de
la deuxième demi finale s'est jouée dès
lé premier tie-break ici donc avec une
partie nulle en première au pjak rami
avec les blancs et un atelier pour une
année noire est donc la seconde on a vu
aussi donc cette magnifique victoire qui
aurait pu se terminer
d'ailleurs en milieu de jeu mais qui a
été poussé jusqu'en finale comme on l'a
vu quand vous voyez même à 2500 îlots
eux mêmes pour les grands maîtres comme
ça de top niveau
eh bien parfois en partie rapide les
positions peuvent se retourner un c'est
pas c'est pas certain que l'on gagne
même qu'une pression supérieure quand on
n'a pas beaucoup de temps et les
positions peuvent se retourner on peut
concéder le nul voire même parfois d'une
position gagnant de se retrouver en
position perdante
donc il faut rester concentré toute la
partie voilà donc la finale de ce
championnat du monde 2015 opposera donc
natalia pogo nina la russe face à maria
musi choo
craignent n donc on a un match russie
ukraine qui n'est pas sans nous rappeler
et bien l'actualité géopolitique du
moment c'est assez assez remarquable
comme ça qu'on ait une finale de
championnat du monde entre la russie et
l'ukraine avec tout ce qui se passe au
niveau géopolitique
ces dernières années voilà donc merci de
m'avoir suivi sur deluna tv pour les
demi-finales et puis bien sûr je vous
donne rendez-vous pour commenter cette
très attendue finale du championnat du
monde 2015 donc entre natalia pogo nina
et maria musi tchouk merci à tous à
bientôt sur les modèles tv